يعني خالد لو ستايل تحول الى ستايل من
البشر كما تشاهد في عمق الصوره ولكن هنا
مشجعون من لبنان ارجنتينيه ومن السودان
فرنسي يعني الارجنتين اليوم لبنانيه
وفرنسا سودانيه طيب كيف بتشجعي فريق
الارجنتين وهل تروح رايحه على المباراه
ولا لا
عايشين نحنا مع ميسي نحنا اكيد بنقول انه
ناسيه حياه اخذها هذه السنه لانه هو
نعتبره هو ابن مرضانه وبيستحقه
فرجع الكل انه هو افضل لاعب
بمباراه هولندا ومع كرواتيا ان هو اليد
الارجنتين فاكيد اليوم هتكون فاموس
ارجنتينو وان شاء الله اكيد
خالد تعدد الطرق ولكن الهدف واحد هالمره
احمر الشفاء ازرق وابيض والعيونر
تشجيع كل واحد الى طريقته شكرا لك سمعينا
شيء من الهتافات
اللي حدك انا بدي اوجه تحيه لقطر بدي اقول
لهم الامير الوالد انه حلم هيدا الحلم
ابنه حققه مذهله نحنا براد اوف قطر
الحمد لله شفتوا انتم من افضل افضل
المونديالات اللي ما راقت على كل العالم
شكرا خالد ما ننسى انه اليوم الوطني لذلك
يوجد الحدود الذين يتواجهون الى الملعب
الاستاذ خلف الكاميرا وكذلك الذي يحتفلون
في عمق الصوره انت هلا السودان سمعناها شو
حكت شو بدك تحكي بالدافع يا اخ يا سوداني
عن فرنسا اليوم على
في الاول يعني بنحيي دوله قطر على هذا
التنظيم الرائع التنظيم الخرافي الذي ابهر
العالم اجمع يعني وكله اجمع على احسن نسخه
نظمت في العام 20 22 و صراحه
اليوم اليوم انا ان شاء الله مشجع للمنتخب
الفرنسي وانا كنت مشجع له في مونديال 2018
بروسيا على الملعب بعد شويه فايت على
الملعب بعد شويه ان شاء الله
قليلي بلو مثلا فيفا لافرانس فيفا ههه
مبابي
والكثير من الجمهور برضه
بيحب اهدي اللقب ايضا لميسي لكن طيب عندي
سؤال
[تصفيق]
حب انت لاحظ الجمهور الارجنتيني والفرنسي
بقطر عم يتبادل الهتافيت مع ابتسامه وهيدا
الشيلي ميز قطر الروح الرياضيه المميزه
هيئه السينما لانه قبل كان السيسي كثير
مشاكل فانا عايده بنفارجه قد ايه قطر
حاولت انه تفرجي حب بين المشجعين الفرنسيه
والارجنتينيه انا بقولنا ميسي اكيد
حياخدها ومارادونا الله يرحمه بس اكيد هو
هلا بعرف
انا ادافع عن المنتخب الفرنسي المنتخب
الفرنسي غير غريب عليه البطولات ودي دي دي
مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي مو اول مره ياخذ لقب
وهمم تيم جاهز حتى الاحتياط ممكن جاهزين
اكثر من المنتخب الاول شكرا لك على كل حال
[تصفيق]
كاس العالم راح نشوف الرابع
[موسيقى]
كوبا الانطلاق سافرت المباراه النهائيه
بين ارجنتين ميسي وفرنسا مبابي كل التوفيق
للمنتخبين تهانينا القطريين والقطر ايضا
العيد الوطني وبهذا التنظيم ايضا رائع
لكاس العالم 2022 شكرا جزيلا لك ليث من
الدوحه